Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Japanese language
or as it's called in Japanese.
Japanese has around 126 million native
speakers making it the ninth most spoken
language in the world.
If we focus on native speakers alone,
it's spoken mainly in the Northeast
Asian nation of Japan and also to a
limited extent in some immigrant
communities and amongst some elderly
people living in Japan's former colonies
like Korea and Taiwan.
Japanese belongs to the Japonica
language family,
which also includes the endangered Yuku
on languages of Okinawa and the Emami
islands,
but the early history of Japanese and
its relationship to other languages is
largely unknown.
There are theories that the Japanese and
Korean languages share a common ancestor
and there are theories that Japanese and
Korean are part of a wider language
family called the [inaudible] language
family,
which also includes the Turkic
languages,
Mongolian and the tongue gooseneck
but the alltech language family and the
connection between Japanese and Korean
are theoretic there hotly debated and
are not generally accepted.
There are also theories that Japanese
are rose from contact between the
language of the aoe people who migrated
from the North East Asia and mainland
into Japan two to 3000 years ago and the
language or languages of the Jomon
people who were already living there.
But the nature of the languages that
these two groups of people spoke is not
clearly known.
Japanese was not a written language in
its early history during the [inaudible]
period,
which leaves us very little evidence of
what it was actually like during that
time in the third century ce,
the Yamato States in Japan established
relations with China and the next 600
years would be a period of heavy Chinese
influence during which the rulers and
the elite sought to emulate many aspects
of Chinese culture.
Written Chinese was probably introduced
to Japan in the fourth century and since
Japanese had no written form,
classical Chinese became the first
literary language used by the elite.
Later Chinese characters began being
adapted to write Japanese.
The earliest examples we have of
Japanese writing are from the eighth
century and there are two forms,
cumbersome and manual.
Ghana come Boone's.
What's the writing of Japanese in
classical Chinese style using Chinese
characters to represent the meaning of
Japanese words.
These texts were essentially Chinese,
but were intended to be readable in
Japanese.
Manual in Ghana was a way of writing
Japanese entirely in Chinese characters
with most of the characters representing
the phonetic sound of the underlying
Japanese syllables.
For example,
the Japanese word for Mountain Yama was
written using these two Chinese
characters for their phonetic value
rather than using the Chinese character,
which means mountain,
which is the character used today and
not one Chinese character was used for
each sound.
Numerous different characters could be
used to represent the same sound.
For example,
the syllable car.
It could be represented by any of the
following characters,
writing Japanese characters phonetically
using Chinese characters that had no
connection to the meaning must have felt
like a lot of unnecessary hard work.
So two systems of simplified phonetic
characters developed from the manual
Ghana System in the eighth and ninth
centuries.
In order to simplify the writing
process.
These two systems where she had a gunner
and Katakana,
one of the main uses of these new kinds
of systems was to annotate,
to combine texts so that Japanese
speakers could read these classical
Chinese or Chinese style texts as though
they were Japanese.
Chinese characters represented the
meaning of the content words while come
up provided the pronunciation as well as
the grammatical elements and inflections
that were not present in Chinese.
Some diacritic markers also indicated
how to change the word order when
reading the text in Japanese.
This method of annotating Chinese texts
with Kona was the precursor to the
modern Japanese writing system.
Through this process of trying to make
the written Chinese language fit with
the spoken Japanese language,
a huge amount of Chinese vocabulary
entered Japanese Chinese characters
where sometimes annotated to be
pronounced with their Chinese
pronunciation known as on your me and
sometimes pronounced as a native
Japanese word with a similar meaning.
These pronunciations are known as who
Naomi.
Such Chinese words have become an
integral part of Japanese comprising 60%
of the total vocabulary,
particularly in writing.
During the late middle Japanese period
from the year 1185 to 16 hundreds
Japanese continued to develop and move
to closer towards modern Japanese
pharmacologically.
In particular towards the end of this
time period in the year 1543 the first
Europeans visited Japan and some
European vocabulary entered Japanese
through contact with traders and
missionaries.
This contact mostly came to a halt
during the period of national isolation
from 1603 to 1853 during this time,
contact with foreigners was strictly
limited to a couple of specific places
like the Dutch trading post dead Jima in
Nagasaki.
A significant number of Dutch loan words
did enter Japanese during this time
period.
Some of them common everyday words like
from clueless,
from lump,
from coffee,
from cope.
These words are examples of lone words
aside from Chinese borrowings and
compounds.
Normally loan words from European
languages,
which are normally written in Katakana.
This period of isolation took place
during the Ed Oh period during which the
Capitol moved from conside to adal.
Present Day Tokyo and the Ed or dialect
became the standard variety of Japanese
after this period of isolation ended in
1853 interaction with the.